we're here at uh Daei my unmarked cafe
by hem our Mayan Martin is that in Burma
yes yeah that is Burma and it's Burma
Myanmar is Burma I don't know [ __ ]
see that's the thing about me - I don't
lie about the stuff that I don't know
about what the [ __ ] we are out here
we're about to grub but we get some
[ __ ] Burmese food if you guys don't
know where Burma is you're obviously
stupid as [ __ ] and you're just like me I
just found out that Burma's next to
Thailand in between India and China I
don't know what the food is like but I'm
pretty sure that's influenced by the
people around them have you guys had
Burmese Buddhist uh no no I've never had
Burmese what is the light a Burmese coot
is like I have no [ __ ] clue cuz I've
never eaten before but we're here to try
new things
we're living out loud last time we had
indonesian food speak indonesian to each
other right now Indonesian Indonesian
and Chi know they are not on takes every
bunch of you go yeah I got em they're
talking [ __ ] aren't you gonna tell me
but I got duck tongue so they fit bang
bang that ping pong ball professor ping
go let's go
when it comes to LA I think one of the
biggest blessings that we have is that
we're very culturally diverse
specifically when it comes to Asian food
and culture I thought Burma was right
next to Indonesia I was wrong anyway
we're you know American yeah see I told
you guys there's no point in being
pretty when you're dumb as [ __ ] when he
was calling you over yesterday he made
this really loud screech and I don't
know who made that noise that's the
noise
Oh God that's really good that's really
good tyrannical I'm ready
the fiery hell gets it now okay you're
gonna do it over here hello
what the fun who is this oh my god you
sound cute yourself
do you do you would you like would you
like to [ __ ] some time so when I came to
Burmese food I really didn't know what
to expect when you kind of open up the
menu everything looks very intense and
because it's a cuisine I've never tried
before I'm a little bit timid but here's
the thing when you try new foods just do
it all balls out don't have any kind of
like preconceived notion about what you
think is supposed to taste just give it
a go if you like it you like it if you
don't you don't so we got the pork mix
and this is like very quintessential in
a lot of Asian foods they call it Oh
fall so it's basically all like
throwaway parts so one thing that I know
Americans do your hang for the throwaway
parts yeah yeah but that's the [ __ ] -
like I'm gonna be I think I'm white
because this I'm scared of it
specially genuinely scared you got join
you gotta try a purse - no no I'm not
one first uh you guys haven't even
prayed like I'm gonna die okay then pray
first pray for yourself there's a lot of
please pray for Yoshi stomach and I pray
that he stops being a [ __ ] it's good
it's good just like that she goes put in
your mouth okay like a saga how'd she
miss it like you try dude try dude come
on
like it is a sport screen
it's what chewy yeah that is a big
though there's a flavor okay never good
hey my so chewy
when the food came out it turned out I
actually had Burmese food I just didn't
know it was from Burma TV salad
you guys know Matt Matt you went on the
first episode of living out loud if you
haven't seen it go watch it again you
[ __ ] unsupportive [ __ ] but uh TV
salad actually turns out to be one of my
favorite things that I've ever eaten in
life it's very nutty it's it's it's
super herbaceous delicious mmm really
good
I did not even have that much flavor you
know what was it mom yeah salty its
nutty it has great texture to it and the
jeely flavor is very prevalent it's not
something that you just kind of like
pass by
this is probably one of my favorites all
they let me do holy [ __ ] I don't even
like something we can talk about the
mutton pancakes it's not the actual name
of it it's actually a fry bread with
whatever protein that you want we had it
with sheep which is mutton you can have
with beef or chicken but it was
personally one of my favorite dishes oh
yeah right so it's like a myth for me
between an onion pancake and then we
have man cheap stuff is that what she
said something rush me a buck from Korea
yep it's a noodle dish don't know what
this is this is like a mung bean
varieties
yeah it looks good right cilantro the
tomatoes we have some hard-boiled eggs
on the side and the function is wet
chicken chicken let's have you mix it up
it doesn't taste like any noodles I've
ever had a great food yeah it's like
almost Swedish this is the chicken along
with Swedish this isn't amongst 160 this
is a chickpea food that's really good
that's good too I like this one
Ono is actually a curry chicken and
coconut milk broth it was very delicious
now the interesting thing about this
dish is that visually it looks very very
very intense but it's not it's super
mild in flavor so the one thing about it
I noticed about type of house it has a
very strong flavor
whether it's like super sweet super sour
stuff it's already this one kind of has
like that lookup type of language it's
not as strong so it doesn't mind a lot
of Indonesian food there's like it's
hard to like pinpoint you can't really
taste too much of this and that's it the
mix of every good
next up we have a dish called ma Jinga
she the waitress actually recommended
this to us catfish do you guys like
cilantro yeah and then we will spritz a
little lime in there and then we'll add
just a little spice oh my god on this
side on the side it's just like a sort
of meat that's a ultimately in soup I
kind of use the same things so I do
think there's like you could taste a
little bit of impulses from the country
that's around me you know has a little
bit of Thai flavor here there's a little
bit of Indian this is good one of the
dishes that the waitresses recommended
was this dish that was made of these
rice noodles and just a whole bunch of
what I call pork garbage it's not trash
per se but it's just a bunch of pork
parts that was a some kind of green
vegetable I think it was bok choy or
some sort very good she said it was
something that everybody gets and it's a
dish that's very representative of
Burmese food I love the little pork
balls I don't know what it's made out of
completely because I think it's some
type of meatball with other stuff in it
but freaking delicious the desserts that
we had was very interesting we had three
different cakes one was made at a
tapioca the other was made of semolina
wheat and the third was made on a
cassava it looks like bacon oh go ahead
give it a go dude I love baking [ __ ]
little disappointed a little I'm making
it off it's good oh it just looks like a
raw piece of fat yeah I feel like it's
like so bad kleavon has a chewy mochi
like texture to it yeah it's pretty good
I like that
oh my god that's one's really good
that's one that's one that's one really
do this that's the one that really good
as I mentioned before one of the best
things in LA is the fact that we get to
experience so many different cultures in
such a small area a lot of the times
would you want to go is fierce the types
of foods or cuisines you have to go fly
to that place but in LA that's not the
case like for me
I like to understand cultures through
food food is a great gateway for you get
to understand a cultures history and
past and also its people there's a lot
of love in it that you don't get to see
in any other type of way and it's do
that sensory of a paste so we just had
our first Burmese food excursion and
Dali my n mark cafe you could see them
there at Monterey Park California on
North Google Drive so check them out
they let us film here my favorite
waitress is back there give her some
spotlight what do you think my food it
was good it's actually really really
good I've never had burmese news is very
much reminiscent of Indonesia I would I
should say Sara it's a bit yeah it's
like mother version of Thai and
Indonesian it was good I mean I don't
think all these episodes like i'ma know
exactly what I'm gonna be eating or what
I'm getting into
yeah that's the fun of it yeah so what
do you get your like devices from or
like either this was from this full
alright nice usually to like with food I
like to experiment like trying new
things you should try to end sex up you
guys I've heard of is like in the back
it would actually in what